graba esto dice nos han robado a
nuestros familiares emociones
desbordadas a las afueras del campamento
de cultura long en el sur de bangladesh
el jueves cuando los primeros autobuses
llenos de refugiados rohingyas partían
con destino una isla en la bahía de
bengala el gobierno afirma que estas
reubicaciones son voluntarias pero para
los devastados miembros de las familias
que vieron ver la partida de los
autobuses esto es mucho más que un
empujón es obligado mi yerno no quería
ir literalmente lo obligaron a subir a
bordo amenazaron con matarlos si no lo
hacían
están obligando a mi hijo ya su familia
a irse vine a verlo tal vez por última
vez
bangladesh está convencido de que este
plan aliviará la presión sobre los
abarrotados campamentos de refugiados en
cox pasan cerca de la frontera con
mianmar donde cientos de miles de
rohingyas se han refugiado después de
vivir de una violenta represión hace
tres años el primer grupo de más de 1500
personas fue transportado en autobús al
puerto de chittagong antes de ser
embarcado hacia una pequeña porción de
tierra de 52 kilómetros cuadrados
conocida como bazar una isla que emergió
del mar hace apenas dos décadas los
lugareños dicen que es propensa a las
inundaciones y que los tifones son un
fenómeno regular como se ve en las
fotografías las instalaciones de la isla
pueden acomodar hasta 100.000 personas
muchos de los refugiados llevan vagando
durante años huyendo de la violencia que
viven en mianmar donde no son
reconocidos como ciudadanos
no somos ciudadanos de ningún país por
lo tanto nos estamos trasladando donde
haya más instalaciones para nosotros la
oficina regional de naciones unidas dice
que no ha podido evaluar la seguridad de
la isla y ha participado en los
preparativos para este proyecto de
reubicación